I'm not here for friends yeah I'm  aggressive  I'm not going to fade to the back  luckily this olivia is a liar what she  says means nothing  I have to ask you about Olivia because I  thought she was a front-runner she got  the first rose but then it looks like  maybe some drama goes down you know I'm  excited for everybody to get to know a  bit more I think you know she and  everybody will get to know Olivia a lot  better even starting this week Ben is  who I want and Ben is who I'm gonna go  after there's just a lot of tension in  the house because she walked in on  Jubilee giving Ben a massage Jubilee cuz  there's also a scene where she's like  giving you a massage and things look a  little baby I love massages by the way